it's on the bound for the padres is
chris paddy
13th start for the 25 year old
right-hander
second career against these red legs
he's now allowed three runs or fewer and
seven his last eight outings
chris paddock has completed his warm-ups
victor caratini has thrown down to
second base
stepping up to the plate for the reds is
jonathan india his big home run last
night
to right field this time myers over
towards the line
is there for out number one one down in
the first for
jesse winker that's what has fouled off
the
home plate umpire the crew chief larry
van over that mass comes flying off
their umpires checking on him and the
padres trainer as well
and we talk about players being gamers
there's a gamer right there and larry
van over
paddock will get the straight three call
first strike
out of the night for chris paddocks out
number two of the first to our base
runner for the left hand hitting tyler
naquin
to first and hosmer will take it to the
bag himself they face tony santion
had a nice outing major league debut is
what you're looking at right here 97
pitches he walked four and he hit two
batters so he had a little bit of a
command problem some of that would be
due to nerves
same electric field tonight as we had
last night
at petco park carry over into tonight's
game no doubt
damned a deep break field castiano's
back at the whoa
it's gone tommy pham starts tonight
off with a bang lead off home run for
fam padres lead at one to nothing oh
that's fantastic
four seamer leaks outer third takes it
the opposite way
tommy can you hear me and just like that
the chance
let's go padres and fam puts him on the
board
so two down manny machado digging in
manny it's a big hit into left center
see if he gets two out of this he is
headed for second thinking he might
throw not in time double
for manny machado with two down right
out of the box
manny machado gets the fastball up
rifles it to left center and he can
smell
two little bubble in between so homepod
umpire
larry van over the crew chief who was
hit on a foul ball
hung in there for an inning and then
walked down into the padres dugout in
between innings
and looks like he's going to go get
checked out and that means another
umpire will have to
put on the gear and head behind the
plate that's going to take some time so
we're going to have a delay here in the
meantime
the scoreboard has been doing some
dancing and the padres dugout has gotten
into the act
ha sung kim i i think he was trying to
be encouraged by fernando dante's junior
dance like nobody's watching levano to
lead it off here in the second inning
swing and a miss for joey votto second
strikeout for paddock one down
really good change up one out here in
the second
eugenio suarez swinging a miss and
paddock with back-to-back strikeouts
three and all
back-to-back punches via the change-up
well that delay
does not seem to affect chris paddock at
all
up to this point swinging a miss and he
strikes out two
and a brilliant one two three second
inning well myers to lead it off here in
the home half of the second inning
oh two hammered to left down the line
gonna go
will myers with a home run and he has
now gone deep more at this ballpark than
any man in padre history
is 58th at petco top of the list
and two to nothing padres in the second
had been tied with adrian gonzalez since
the second week of april been a while
since he homered at home
and wow just a missile to left so here's
jesse winker he too was a strikeout
victim on a called strike three
bullet in the right center field here
comes myers it hits the ground that will
score farmer
two to one bowl game jesse winker with
his 42nd rbi
the year he hits the first pitch and the
reds have cut the padre lead in half
great effort by myers and that's one of
those kind of all or nothing type of
efforts here's castellanos winker off
the bag at first
paddock to the plate swinging them in
paddock strikes out castillanos
strikeout number six for paddock
fernando tatis junior leading off he is
homered in three straight and five out
of his last six
lined a fair ball down the left field
line headed towards the corner
fernando's headed for second at least to
pull it up but second base with a double
that starts the bottom of the third
inning
ah the top twist after the double one
out fernando tatis junior at third and
manny machado climbs in the box
fly ball center field naquin going back
and he'll make the catch
on the warning track front of the walls
to tease tags and scores
and the padres take a 3-1 lead now
farmer
motto's on third here suarez first and
farmer over tatis
volo scores reds get their second tally
it's a one run game
will myers one of the two padre home
runs in this ball game his came in to
lead off things in the second
fly ball deep left center field for
myers they quit going back and it is
gone into the bullpen
will myers with a two-home run nice
we're just in the fourth inning
home runs seven and eight on the year
for myers a solo shot
gives the padres a 4-2 lead four-seed
fastball
right down the middle who doesn't love a
four-seamer right down the middle the
perfect swing
for perfect results and the padres get
that run back
that will load them up for fernando
tatis jr
on the ground left side and through base
hit
from third comes cronenworth caratini
will be stopped at third and the padres
late at 5-2
fernando tatis jr driving in a run so
it's on to the fifth
as jonathan india top of the reds order
strike three call make it ten strikeouts
for paddock one down in the fifth inning
and this time with the old number two
the curveball
okay into the teeth of this reds order
nick castellanos coming up
swinging a miss and castillano strikes
out and strikeout number 11
for paddock ties a career high two down
as we head to the bottom of the fifth
inning eric hosmer will lead things off
ashton godeau
on for his second inning of work swing
and hosmer drives one deep left field
going back winker
he's at the wall leaps and he
didn't catch it it's gone no he didn't
catch it wow
what a play by winker at the left field
wall
spectacular glove by winker to take away
a homer
and then nonchalantly walk back towards
the infield
as if he had not caught it and hasbro
can't believe it he thought he had a
second home run in as many nights
so now lefty to lefty do little to
cronin andre is trying to add to their
three run lead here in the seventh
inning
fly ball struck well to left field
winker going back
at the wall can't get this it's over his
head around from second comes machado
jake chronoworth drives in the padres
sixth round at 6-2
san diego jake going the opposite way
driving one in and the padre's hot on
that's a huge run
tatis will turn the baton over to trent
christian two on one out
for the padres center fielder hendricks
set now the pitch and trent swings hits
the ground ball to the right side
that'll get
past bottom into right field for a base
hit both runs will score
bam is in here comes tatis grisham to
second with a two run double
and an eight to two padre lead in the
eighth so stevenson will pinch it
we have two outs and a runner on first
and adams kicks in deals in the ground
ball to third base manny backhand near
the line
off balance throw across the diamond
hosmer scoop
he got him what a play by manny machado
to end the game
just classic manny being manny over at
the hot corner and the padres make it
two in a row over the reds
final score tonight 8-2